welcome to the National Fish and
Wildlife forensics laboratory in Ashland
Oregon our laboratory works very much
like a Police Crime Lab in that we
identify evidence and we try to link
suspect victim and crime scene together
for that evidence the big difference is
that our victim is a nonhuman animal I'm
Ken Goddard and the director of its
laboratory when our agency's evidence at
a border a custom Center wherever that
evidence will be packaged and shipped to
us our job is to analyze evidence
collected for wildlife law enforcement
investigations our laboratory primarily
supports wildlife laws in general
specifically the Endangered Species Act
sadly were the only full-service crime
lab for wildlife in the world like not
to be but that's our reality the illness
and wildlife trade is huge it's probably
in the neighborhood of 17 18 19 billion
dollars we're certainly impacting the
trade but it's a desperately difficult
job here are some of the scientists that
help us solve crimes against animals our
veterinary pathologist is dr. Becky
Kagan my job is to autopsy all of the
animals that come in here and try to
figure out why they died today I have a
two birds they're both bald eagles
they're wild animals they're found dead
my job is to figure out what their crime
involves we can do CT scanning here's
the lab we take photographs we'd
alternate light source exam to help us
solve the puzzle of what animal died one
aspect of our work that's typical of a
crime lab is we compare a known against
an unknown for us to identify let's say
a feather or maybe to identify the bones
we would compare that against tissue
from a known animal or of the skeleton
and the fellow responsible for our huge
collection is Johnny French our
collection is 35,000 specimens give or
take everything that we have here is
either being donated or was seized in
customs the uniqueness of our collection
helps us kind of keep abreast of what we
see
in the wildlife trade most of the time
we have to remove meat from bone in
order to examine specimens or to get
them into our reference collection
easiest way to do that is take the
carcass and check it in the flesh-eating
beetles ink after the beetles have
finished with the carcass that we threw
in there we'll wash them a couple of
times and then the bones are ready for
the collection heading up our genetics
section is dr. Mary Curtis the genetics
team is important to the functioning of
the lab because we look at items that
other parts of the lab can't identify
items that might be crafted to the point
where you can't tell what their origin
is so we have access to over 40,000
individual tissue samples in our
reference collections that we need to
identify different species one of the
more interesting people in our lab it is
off your pepper trail our ornithologist
I'm an ornithologist a bird expert so I
look at Verte evidence and use reference
specimens to compare to evidence items
to confirm identification the kinds of
evidence that we received is incredibly
buried we receive everything from
complete egg carcasses in good condition
to just bags of bones I've identified
over 750 species in the course of my
work here which would be a pretty good
life list for a lot of birders the
magnitude of the international wildlife
trade is staggering every day into our
laboratory comes remains of dead animals
from around the world and someone needs
to provide the information needed to
bring wildlife feminist
it's sometimes a sad job but it's a very
important job and I'm talking about
you